[Music]
what happened would happen to my lakers
they're the worst team in basketball reg
year Theodore as well as to my Dennett's
Mary Kwanzaa Happy Hanukkah can I ask
you a question because yeah before I
answer your lakers yep question yeah I
value your opinion as well as my damage
you guys are worldly people well
educated men when is it appropriate to
stop saying happy new year to people and
happy holidays you mean what day yeah oh
okay I myself continuing to say happy
new year to people but it's January
third no cutoff date now we had a rule a
couple years ago didn't we Pauly yes we
are saying the absolute max you must
stop before the second monday in january
once the second work week starts there's
no more happy new year even if you
haven't seen the person at all the
second month or happy new year okay to
follow up question when do I take down
the tree I'm leaving mine up as long as
possible why because it's Christmas
isn't a day reg it's a spirit oh my god
just God oh the Holy Ghost have touched
me here at Malibu who has the best
Christmas decorations in Malibu any
celebrities gotta really like kick-ass
holiday decorations not really no no no
you got to go elsewhere you got to leave
Malibu really sorry yeah it's a bummer
but you're really leaving your tree up
until all year really not all year i'm
gonna guess by next week the end of next
week i'll probably take ok ok i'm just
trying to get this all down ok happy
holidays over by next monday tree comes
down shortly thereafter got it ok the
lakers well wait a min i gotta ask you
women hold on
wait I gotta ask you this mariah carey
for Mariah por mariah me and Mariah go
back like baby so pacifier here's the
thing we know she is notorious for not
going to sound check that is true it
isn't that isn't that one of the most
important things for an artist if you
want to make sure you are on point if
you want to make sure your material
sounds like the way you sing it and what
and the way you want people to hear it
you would think soundcheck would be very
important now again you and I are not
privy we don't know she did sound check
her not she's my history did not bring
by the history of Mariah Carey so
there's only one person to blame here
and it's not Dick Clark or whoever that
she said secret him up yeah okay Ryan
Seacrest did not into Center oh come on
yeah I like how they said she said they
sabotaged her but then they tried to
help her by shouting shooting the
audience so they they wouldn't shoot her
when she bought the backup dancers the
little elves in the in the air they
tried to shoot everyone and Mariah just
could not leave herself off the mic how
do you forget your song seriously now
you never come along you never dated her
right no okay just why it was a lot of
people date where I or something yeah
apparently oh no never suggest that a
memo there was a pause there that when I
said did you date because I was
ridiculous it was a pause okay what's
wrong with my lakers by the way use you
know we talked about this a month and a
half ago when you were so high on them
really two months ago yes there you're
going to get what you get certain games
they're going to play like gangbusters
everyone's all clicked in and they're
playing well and then they're going to
show their age multi december two and 14
the worst month ever for a Laker team so
they showed their age you know I've had
in the last two weeks
yet I'm in Miami and then we had them at
home vs dallas and they get off to these
great leads they're playing great and
according to Luke Walton they lose focus
would you both young team to do they've
lost focus all right here's the other
thing and that is James Harden stat line
I think it might be it is it the second
greatest stat line in NBA history aside
from lil putting up a hundy behind will
I believe behind will or it's similar to
what wilt did you know 4050 years ago
let me just say this and this shows you
how funny and cynical the NBA is James
Harden this is the same guy that
averaged what 28 29 points and six and
six a year ago and was left off all
three all-nba teams mm-hmm this is the
same James Harden just a year before
that was runner-up to the MVP behind
Steph and now he's back to having an MVP
career year and you know a 50-plus
trippy triple-double and now he's
writing to the discussion with MVP with
Westbrook it just show it makes me laugh
like how could anyone leave this guy off
all three and maybe you give them you
know third team all-nba how can he be
left off all three all-nba teams are you
kidding me we were it the media must be
idiot seriously yeah it looks idiot we
are absolutely we are but why is it
nobody brings up Steph Curry's lack of
defense but we bring up James Harden
lack of defense well because Steph for
all these years Golden State was known
as a great defensive team and Steph
always had those bigs behind them like
on Andrew Bogut cleaning up the messes
we always see the videos in the YouTube
videos of James Harden getting lost on
defense he didn't have a last line of
defense Steph always did as well as he
had guys on the edges like draymond
Green klay Thompson Andre Iguodala who
were fantastic defenders who cleaned up
a lot of mess step isn't great but he
also is in bed the same same
James Harden James Harden is in a
terrible defender but he doesn't have a
last line of defense like Steph always
had what Steph looks like he cares about
defense a little bit James looks like he
doesn't care at all I think I think it's
more of what it looks like than what it
really is and also let's say this to
just last year steph led the league in
steals now he was afforded the luxury of
being able to gamble because of that
last line of defense if you look at his
steel numbers this year because there
are much smaller team he doesn't have
that luxury so that's why his steals are
down this year we're talking to Reggie
Miller Reggie's got Lakers Blazers
thursday night at ten thirty eastern why
is George Karl writing a book well man I
I don't know it's it's gotten to the
point where it's really sad and you know
if you have your own personal feelings I
get that and if you you know you want to
be vocal about it you have every right
to do that but some of the things he's
talking about he has no knowledge of
like the whole damian lillard a and yes
he knows their head coach Terry Stockman
he knows nothing nor does he know Damian
Lillard so how you gonna throw Lillard
under the bus by saying he must be a
terrible teammate when you've never ever
met the guy when you've never ever seen
him practice known as a person it's it's
become sad because you know I've known
George for a long time he was my Olympic
coach in 19 or 2002 and it's sad because
his knowledge of the game in the time in
the years that he has put in I mean he's
one of what four or five coaches to win
a thousand games so he's seen a lot but
to spill the beans like this it's
unfortunate because not only is he
hurting his Hall of Fame chance because
he's a Hall of Fame coach come on you
don't want a thousand games without
being a hall-of-fame coach he's really
hurting his chances for the hall and
he's just turning his back on a lot of
people that supported him yeah it just I
don't I don't know he just went out of
his way you get from it if not like
writing this book is
to make you I mean hopefully you had
enough money through coaching yeah
playing you know hopefully that's your
nesting what are you really gaining by
doing this book are you releasing some
demons that you've always wanted to do I
mean and plus we all have skeletons in
our closet and when you start throwing
those rocks at those glass houses rocks
start to come back at you and you start
to hear how he was lobbying for all
these jobs while coaches were still you
know employed by those teams your dirty
laundry starts to come up now and now
you've got to look at yourself in the
mirror so the things that you didn't
like and that you're mentioning by
players not practicing hard and you know
showboatin and only caring about money
and fame well now they're starting to
kind of look at you a little bit as well
it's almost like he wants to let people
know how tough his job was that he was
able to get these results but look at
what i had to put up with I is the only
thing I can think what all our jobs were
tough as well I mean you you go to the
grave with your secrets if that's how
you really feel about Carmelo is that
how you really feel about Kenyon Martin
jr. Smith Lillard take it to the grave
with you take it I mean all these people
that supported you throughout your your
cancer I mean it makes people like
scratch their head like where is this
really coming from because he's really a
good guy if you got to know George call
he really is a good guy does he shoot
from the hip at times yes but that's
behind closed doors to write a book
about it and just to bring all this up I
mean a lot of these things need to be
handled behind closed door it really
does and I like George Karl I do reg is
calling Lakers Blazers Thursday night no
I'm excited that I'm going to make it it
is going to be a great Miller's back
Gigi Becali coming off a career high 43
the game is going to be on point at a
boy implicitly NBA on TNT check it out
the Lakers are back can you do this for
me as a shout out to the show to start
the new year and give me a whose stats
what you want
would you want yeah dirty but getting it
right yeah okay yeah this is how it says
seat and get reduced Ed's who stats
would you want tell me tell me tell me
mmm sticks to talk about that if Kevin
Hart a little bit crazy like what are
you doing my boss is from turner call me
up but I will do my bit like a statue
that do you want a reg I like it happy
new year happy new you i have until next
monday then right happy new year
everyone so if you see me throughout
malibu and I'm like saying happy Malibu
are happy about last few years this is
the reason why and I'm keeping my tree
up until after all-star game I love it
thanks reg you get the best view door I
love you dad at Reggie Miller the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]